c'est le moment le plus merveilleux de
la cuisine on
dirait que Martha Stewart vomit
ici c'est un miel délicieux un peu
sec
bien le mien est délicieux le mien est sec tu
veux échanger ce n'est pas Noël c'est
Noël c'est Noël avec ces
salutations de vacances
comment nous allons  survivre à Noël avec
12 personnes coincées dans une maison sans
chauffage ni électricité ni nourriture il y a
beaucoup de restes de bière Howard c'est tellement
étrange qu'il n'y a pas de voitures personne
combien de temps cela peut-il continuer nous avons entendu
quelque chose dans le toit l'enfer est ce
Saint  Nicholas ne vient pas cette année à la
place un esprit ancien beaucoup plus sombre
ce sont des élans de hos qui font une sorte de promenade de chèvre
sur ses pattes arrière
son nom est Krampus
lui et ses aides ne sont pas venus donner
mais pour prendre tout le monde se tenir les uns les
autres
il est le  ombre de st.  Nicholas c'est
Noël rien de mal ne va arriver à
Noël